Steve I know our audience has an
interest not only in technology per se
but also in how technology is changing
the way we work does the past burns the
New York Times has run numerous articles
in how this or that technology threatens
to change how we've historically done
things or bring about some fundamental
change in the industry for how firm
operates here is some headlines it's all
publishing by authors threatens
publishing houses computers great essays
makes life easier professors allow
students to get more feedback on their
writing MOOCs educate the world and
eliminate middle tier universities and
there been articles on Google Glasses an
article on turn your cell phone into a
credit card reader similarly 60 minutes
carried a story on how sensors will
allow people those manufacturing
producers of new technologies regularly
traffic and claims but miraculous
changes of their technology will bring
about in the valley we even have a name
for people whose job it is to stellas on
the miracles that will be wrought by new
technologies technology evangelist see
what's right see when you read this kind
of articles or hear about new
technologies that are being evangelist
Peter I suspect that some of these
technologies will have significant
effects and a few may even transform our
entire society or at least continue
transformations that are already
underway but most will actually become
effects that are confined to particular
jobs or firms or industries and after 35
years of studying how technology in
effect work I'm skeptical of one of the
effects that we anticipate when we adopt
the new technology are the only ones
that will occur and more importantly
whether the effects we anticipate will
turn out to be most consequential
history repeatedly tells us that the
unanticipated consequences of
technological change that bring about
are those that bring about the biggest
changes in our lives our cultures and
society if fact I'm were convinced that
there's only one law technological
change
and since I don't have any grandsons
I've been named after me yet we'll just
call this barleys law bodies law says
you almost never get only what you
expect and most of the time you don't
even get that the law has a corollary
and the corollary is however something
happens the truth is we typically adopt
technologies only with what we might
call first order effects in mind but it
is usually the technology second order
effects that pack the biggest wall first
order effects tend to be economic they
increase efficiency they save as time
they make us more effective they reduce
labor costs they also tend to occur
relatively quickly they are practical in
their orientation or at least we see
them as practical they're relatively
predictable and by and large they're not
all that hard to measure in fact is Bob
Thomas pointed out in this book what
machines can't do we usually can't get
authorization to buy a new technology
and Leslie convince upper management
that will have economic benefits so
people go out of their way to make such
a case even if they want the in
technology for entirely different
reasons for example simply because it's
cool this is the culture of business
ironically after demanding economic
benefits most firms don't ever bother to
figure out whether they achieve them or
not second order effects are quite
different these tend to be
socio-cultural they change the way you
see things how we interact with each
other how we think of ourselves our
perceptions of time our expectations of
each other these changes tend to be slow
but in the end they're pervasive they
creep up on us one day we wake up and
wonder how the hell we got here they're
critical but they're not necessarily
practical they're hard to predict
consequently they're hard to measure you
give us an example of the technology the
second-order effects have been more
important than a first order effects
email is a good example because it's
been around long enough for us to
experience both its first and second
order effects most organizations adopt
email because it allows quicker
communication especially over long
distances it eliminates the cost of
postage stationery Secretary of Labor
and it is an asynchronous medium which
allows messages and responses to be
separated by a span of time in other
words because email we no longer had to
play phone tag two and a half decades
later we're also quite familiar with the
symptoms of emails second-order effects
most of us feel like we're drowning an
email we even think we know why first
there's constant spam then there's all
the CCS we get so we really don't think
we need it third comes email at night
its arrival is relentless then there is
a distribution list that usually carry
relatively unimportant if not actually
useless information in fact we are so
aware of the overwhelming volume of
messages we get that we complain
constantly about not being able to get
our real work done many of us see email
as a significant source of stress
several years ago we did a study of
communications and stress among
employees of the well-known Silicon
Valley firm we asked 80 people across
the organization to keep logs of every
work-related communication they had over
the course of three days including
evenings and at least one Saturday or
Sunday we track not only email sessions
but teleconferences meetings voicemail
sessions and face-to-face encounters as
well as phone calls then we have people
fill up stress inventories
from all of this data we could calculate
the number of hours people worked on
these days after our informants
completed the logs we interviewed them
about their work as well as how they
used as what they felt about each of the
various modes of communication despite
what people thought the number emails
they received did not lead them to work
longer hours but the meetings and
teleconferences that they took part in
did cause them to work longer hours
although the volume of email did it
matter however the time they spent doing
it did time spent doing email was the
strongest predictor stress more
importantly email was the only medium
that elicited frustration and anger
Steve why was this wasn't the volume of
email received why did they blame email
from stress they filled why don't people
just reduce the fire hose at least a
garden hose the answer lies in emails
second order effects Peter there were
three of these second order effects
first where the cultural norms that
arose around using email people told us
that they could not nor email because
they were afraid of missing something
that would later be held accountable for
not knowing for this reason they would
not even ignore email from what they saw
as mostly useless distribution lists
they also didn't use filters for this
reason if you're not seeing the message
about what someone would later say hey
did you read my email in sharp contrast
people were rarely asked did you hear
what was said on the teleconference if
you missed a teleconference everyone
knew you missed it and even more
important norm was the expectation of
responsiveness in this organization you
were expected to reply to emails within
hours certainly within a day this norm
was both games and enforced in order
get emails read people labeled less than
urgent emails urgent they had learned to
copy co-workers and bosses to increase
the odds that the target recipient would
reply which of course increased the
number of CCS that people were getting
and the people didn't get an answer
quickly senators would call recipients
on the phone and say didn't you get my
email finally because email was a
synchronous people felt free to send
messages anytime people reasoned that
email would not interrupt co-workers at
home unless their co-workers wanted it
to but the fact but in fact right it was
it was an evening or if it was an
evening or weekend didn't absorb the
recipients from the obligation to reply
quickly everyone told us that it would
be appropriate to call people at night
or on the weekend about work unless it
was a true emergency in fact our
informants received very few phone calls
about work at home but email was not
seen as it interruptions so why didn't
people just ignore the normal well they
were punished when they did people who
did not respond quickly developed a
reputation for being a poor corporate
citizen people feared that such a
reputation would block their careers
another second order effect was that
email made it easier to use distributed
teams most of the people we study were
on many distributed teams and many of
these teams included people located in
Asia and Europe if all you had with
telephones you would never try to call
someone in Europe or Asia before or
after your work day ended but you would
regularly send email and they would send
email to you thus email from Europe and
Asia would begin arriving during the
night so they're guaranteed of waking up
to an active inbox because of this you
woke up feeling you were already behind
the eight ball the problem was
exacerbated by yet another second order
effect how the flow of email inclined
with the flow of other communication
events over the course of the day this
graph plots the frequency of email
sessions against combined frequency of
phone calls conferences and
teleconferences over the course of a 24
hour day as you can't eat as you can see
people started doing email between 5am
and 6 a.m. in the morning their rate of
doing email steadily increased until
around 9am very which climb the
frequency of phone calls meetings and
teleconferences also escalated by 11am
the phone calls meetings and
teleconferences have become and remained
more frequent than email sessions until
around three thirty in the afternoon
what email began again became the most
common form of communication in short
people could not readily attend to
emails that arrived during the prime
hours of the day so at the end of the
day they confronted a backlog of
unanswered email which others expected
them to answer quickly people therefore
spent the early evenings finishing off
email they couldn't answer during the
day in other words because distributed
teams and because of teleconferences
meetings and phone calls email came to
blur the boundary between work and home
was not just the number of hours that
people spent doing email mattered it was
when those hours occurred that
reinforced people associating email was
stressed I mean how many times does your
wife chastise you for doing email at
night instead of paying attention to her
plenty of times to do so why don't
people complain more than they do about
teleconferences meetings and phone calls
well it's legitimate to complain about
email everybody complains even the CEO
complaints but it's not legitimate to
complain about being told you have to
work on distributed teams or that you
have to have teleconferences at all
hours of the day including the morning
in the evening note that the red line on
that graph starts to pick up at 6am it
doesn't fall to zero until nine these
are teleconferences with people with
other time zones imagine that your boss
what your boss would say if you complain
as loudly about being on a distributed
team as you do about email you might get
fired it's simply not acceptable for us
to complain about the business models
that have been foisted on us my point is
email has changed the way we live but
the change wasn't anticipated and it
probably could not have been anticipated
nevertheless it is these second order
changes that are most important in long
run but surely there's something we can
do we could employ filters on or email
we could decide that will only check
emails and batches we could remove
ourselves from distributions risk but
the evidence is that most people don't
stick with these strategies for very
long out of fear of missing something
out of fear falling behind or out of
fear of being deemed unresponsive and
ineffective as a co-worker the only
effective way I have seen to decouple
email from stress and the anxiety have
been when a CEO recognizes the problem
and tells his or her employees not to
answer work-related email before and
after work I know of one employer went
so far as to have his IT people make the
email email servers offline after hours
in other words managers have to tell
their employees they are not expected to
do me email all the time and then you
have to make sure they don't punish them
for not doing so in lieu of a systematic
intervention like this I don't think we
are likely to be effective have dealing
with this problem you have any ideas
about when we can expect a new
technology to have significant
second-order effects little change an
organization you can be sure technology
will change an organization if it begins
to reshape role relationships let me
explain technologies change our work in
two primary ways that can change our
practices what we do and how we do it in
addition technologies can change with
whom we interact or the nature of the
relationships we have with those people
in other words when we do a job we fill
a role petal role has two components
past that people perform in a role and
their interactions with members of their
role set that is the other people with
whom we have to interact in order to get
our job done if you're a technician in
the radiology department your task
involves operating technologies x-ray
machines CT scanners ultrasound machines
to produce medical images in the process
of producing these images you must
interact with radiologists
administrators and patients these are
the members of your all set if your car
sales when your task is a show and sell
cars you do this by repeatedly engaging
in a set of activities like making
customers on test drives and by using a
set of props including automobiles
brochures databases and so on when
selling a car you must also interact
with customers other sales persons and
managers and those are the members of
your all set new technologies almost
always change our work practices how we
do what we do otherwise we would adopt
them but not all technologies change
with whom we interact or the nature of
the relationships we have with those
people if these relationships remain
unchanged the organization remains
unchanged regardless of how much a
change we experience in what we do or
how we do it but if a technology leads
us to interact with people playing
different roles than we interacted with
before or is it significantly changes
the nature of our interactions then we
sure to see organizational change
changes in role relationships alter the
structure of the social networks that
constitute the work system Steve can you
give a specific example the technology
to radically change what people do but
not their relationships Sir Peter for
this way we can stay close to home let's
consider a demonstrative assistance who
used to be called secretaries and
professors the worker professors of
administrative assistants are well our
well-known case of wind technologies
change what people do and how they do it
while leaving role relationships and
thus the social order and
as recently as the 1980s administrative
assistance answering phones interactive
with students kept paper records of
accounts filed documents and type
letters memos and manuscripts for
faculty who often wrote first drafts by
hand today administrative assistants
continue to answer phones and interact
with students but few type documents for
faculty professors now use
microcomputers and word processing
programs to create and revise their own
documents ministration assistants have
been removed from this process an
incidence of what students of technology
called disintermediation as in the past
administrative assistants continue to
manage accounts what they do so using
spreadsheets of the puter ice forms as a
consequence filing no longer requires
rooms filled filing cabinets because of
the increased efficiency of producing of
storing documents and because the
faculty have assumed the task of
producing those documents the
universities now employ fewer
administrative assistants and those are
remain have required new skills and
tasks such as maintenance of websites
nevertheless administrative assistants
continue to have roughly the same
relations with faculty and other staff
they had in the past in short what
administrative assistants do and how
they do it has changed but the work
relationships if not so the way academic
departments are organized today isn't
much that different than how they were
organized before microcomputers came
along what better technology has changed
relations and hence organizations
radiology is a good example some years
ago I did a year of anthropological
research in the radiology department of
two community hospitals during the first
year that they received on their first
CT scanner like other computerized
imaging modalities such as ultrasound
digital subtraction angiography CT scan
there's radically altered the work of
the x-ray technicians who are assigned
to run them technologists who run
computerized technologies have to know
how to read the films that they are
producing in order to capture the
agnostic ly useful information they also
have to know something about computers
this is quite different than traditional
xr8 work where you can produce a medical
useful image largely by knowing how to
position the patient's body relative to
a cathode ray tube the upshot was that
text around the computer modality
developed a very different relationship
with radiologists not only did they
interact more with radiologists and far
less with administrators but their
conversations with radiologists often
focused on pathology which was quite
rare and standard x-ray I can show you
how this change to the organization
during the study i measured who needed
to interact with whom according to job
descriptions also use questionnaires and
observations to figure out who is
actually talking to whom regarding the
work that actually goes on in the
radiology department here's a network of
the radiology department based on job
descriptions the radiologist and
administrators are equivalent in the
sense that technicians report to both
moreover all the technicians are the
same they report to the administrators
and the radiologist and they don't have
interactions with each other the
department as you can see is tightly
integrated into one structure in fact
you see a classic dual hierarchy of a
hospital here's the actual network of
relationships the network indicates the
day-to-day reality for all intensive
purposes the radiology departments are
could the consisted of two different
worlds one centered on routine x-ray and
fluoroscopy it was run by administrators
to whom the x-ray techs reported and
notice that information flowed up from
the x-ray text to the administrators but
not down the other segments of the
radiology department was run by the
radiologists the various texts operating
the computer modalities interacted
professionally with each other as well
as with the radiologists even the nurses
were involved in the network and
interesting so we're secretaries who
book CT scans one side of the
organization
left side was a classic bureaucracy the
other was a network of collegial
interaction this is how computer imaging
had changed social organization and
radiology over a number of years thank
you very much to you I heard a lot this
morning about in Korea that's shaping
our society which is having a lot of
impact on technology companies those in
terms of how they function internally
and how they deliver services to their
customers steve is one of a number of
pop Stanford faculty participate in
Stanford executive Institute vicissitude
has been delivered annually every summer
going back to 1975 and is our
departments cornerstone executive
education program program provides
participants with the general management
and leadership poles successful in the
technology environment unlike many other
programs the teaching cases was
exclusively on technology management and
we carefully select our participants
from technology companies because of its
technology focus there's no better place
than Stanford University deliver a
program at this kind we select faculties
teachers based on both their teaching
abilities and other knowledge of a
high-tech environment for case studies
covert discussions personal coaching
team projects and presentations or just
want to acquire tools and approaches to
take their organizations to the next
level participants learn about business
strategies relevant to the high-tech
industry for using pertinent case
studies and discussions with high tech
executives they gained respect us from
nationally recognized faculty and
industry leaders aligning business
principles with real-life experience
yeah identify practical solutions to
business challenges facing today's tech
executives they practice
entrepreneurship and bring innovative
ideas back into the organization finally
they identify management techniques for
rapid growth competition and innovation
specific topics included in the program
include accounting finance leadership
marketing negotiations and innovation
let me create a couple of quotes from
recent participants in our Institute
this is one John Lamont checked vice
president Priscilla
fine damage quote graduating from the
Institute my increased understanding of
business processes marketing and general
manager does help me grow our business
over fifty percent unquote another quote
John girdim manager for the Boeing
Company quote really a great opportunity
for those endeavouring to run a
high-tech business in today's
environment programs and gents with just
the right balance of debts and breads be
directly applicable to enterprise
leaders unquote this year the Sanford
executive you work around here at
Stanford for August pours through August
test is tarah bear department and one of
the two academic co-directors for the
Institute I encourage you to consider
this program seriously if you had your
technology management skills Evan Steve
we have an opportunity now to take some
questions from our audience so question
number one Steve do you see any emerging
technologies on horizon in which similar
impact will be built on the way we work
well they're undoubtedly quite a number
out Peter but the one that I think is
going to have the longest term in the
impact one that would be building on
what's already been taking place as
opposed to suddenly change thing in a
different direction is the use of sensor
technology in manufacturing well it is
increasingly common using the sensors
and effectors we might call them
robotics we might call them artificial
intelligence but it's really the core of
a sensors and information transfer what
does allows people to do is to build
manufacturing plants in which you really
don't need traditional workers well you
need technicians to maintain the system
but most of in these kinds of plants you
can many of them you can at least in
some types of plants you can bring your
raw materials in and not have a human
being touched them until it's time to
put them in a box and send them away
this is going to have
a major impact on the availability of
manufacturing jobs not only in the arm
not only in the developed economies of
Europe and North America but it will
also eventually have a significant
impact elsewhere in the country which
means that job structures are going to
change and it will have significant
implications I think for worldwide
employment so do you have any sense at
this point as to what the potential
second-order effects might for you in
this case well if you think about a
large group of people Oh being not able
to work perhaps because they don't have
the skills necessary to get a different
kind of job oh then you have large scale
second order of fact you have unemployed
you book likely to have unemployment
rates that are going to rise they will
they will change what will change about
them is you know we will know will no
longer consider oh you know three
percent four percent five percent
unemployment as typical will be talking
about higher levels of continued
unemployment you can take about it will
it will probably also change the
structure of organizations even more
command in running a plant an entire
production planet with simply management
and a cadre of technicians it will make
most manufacturing look more like
they'll make batch manufacturing look
more like continuous flow processes well
that is gasoline refining chemical
production so on and so forth thank you
Steve there's a specific question a
particular industry segment particularly
robotic surgery how do you envision this
technology changing the surgery
workplace robotic surgery is really
quite interesting i'm not an expert in
robotic surgery but i would say there's
two com
owns to this one is that the robot
actually does the surgery and the second
one is what's the role of the human
being with respect to the robot I don't
believe but it could be wrong that is
now possible to program a robot to do
surgery in the same way that you can
program a robot in an automobile plant
to paint a car meaning it runs entirely
off of its own program on and look and
you don't need human intervention that's
not my understanding how robotic surgery
is currently but my understanding is
that it's done with surgeons and
technicians beside patient and it also
opens up the possibility of doing
surgery from afar also that one could
have a surgeon located in California and
a patient located in West Virginia for
example um this is likely to have a
major impact on surgical theaters
particularly the use of distance robots
to allow distance surgery most well
operating surgical theaters today I'll
involve on pike relationships between
surgeons anesthesiologists and nurses
and technicians in fact data show over
and over again on that surgical teams
that have ongoing experience with each
other are far more effective than
surgical teams on that rotate in and out
and so to the degree that we began to
experiment with robotic surgery and it
becomes common you can expect I think
unintended on decrements all in the
precision with which surgical teams and
you know work with each other on in a
surgical theatre very interesting
I think many of the participating in two
very may have any technology management
focus are there any principle takeaways
in terms of what we covering this
morning's that are particularly relevant
for technology managers in particular
what should they be mindful of what I
would urge people to think about as they
adopt new technologies and the hard
thing and thinking about it is you never
really know exactly which ones are going
to have second-order effects and the
reason for this is the second order
effects accumulate gradually but having
said that what I would what I would
recommend or what I was vigilance um
when you adopt a new technology and
people began to behave differently than
they did before you might ask yourself
well is this something we want in the
case of radiology departments that
certainly improve relationships between
radiologists and technicians or is it
something we don't want and what can we
do to intervene and I would argue that
the role that email is played in our
lives is like that however we've now
built such an infrastructure around
using email to communicate that I can't
imagine I can't imagine us be willing to
put large widespread restrictions on how
people actually communicate day in and
day out with Liz email we'll just need
to learn to live with the stress Thank
You Steven we have a few minutes here
funny just take the opportunity to maybe
put a little bit further afield and just
to ask you what's the most interesting
recent research findings are developed
what's my most interesting research
recent research research research Vanya
we recently completed a
a how the Internet has affected
automobile sales and what we found was
quite interesting most most dealerships
adopt the internet sell cars in order to
compete with their competitors and to
increase volume what we found was that
it has an unexpected and unintended
effect on the relationship between
salespeople and car buyer so let me tell
you what we did we went out to two went
out to to war two dealerships one was a
chevrolet dealership and one was a
toyota dealership we spent a year and a
half following sales people from ads ask
customers would come on the lot um we
even recorded interactions between sales
people and their customers and initially
we thought that there would be
differences in the way chevrolet and
toyota sold cars based upon the kinds of
differences at least historically
existed in the way they did their
manufacturing and we found none of that
but what we did find was that there was
a massive difference and how people how
sales people on the floor sold cars and
how people who managed unit sales sold
cars and more importantly the nature of
the relationships that developed between
the customers and their salespeople to
tell you precisely what i mean and
everyone has ever bought in the car will
notice the typical plot of a sales
encounter with a floor salesman as you
will be greeted by the salesperson the
salesperson will begin to notice things
about you that he or she can use to
develop a sense of similarity eventually
you'll get asked to take a test drive
you come back from the test drive and
then and only then will the sales person
sit down to negotiate price now everyone
at least Americans hate buying cars and
the reason to hate buying cars is
because they don't trust cars
salesman cultural image we have they out
there and there they'd lie to you they
engage in behaviors that are unethical
oh now I hope you're not too many cars
now what happens then is that these
relationships break down into conflict
with the internet sales the very first
thing that is talking about is price you
don't come in and drive a car if you
come through the internet until you
settle price more interestingly the
floor salespeople begin with MSRP and
work down to find the prize the internet
sales people work with invoice price and
will typically say the cost will be
invoice price plus three hundred four
hundred dollars which will be our profit
so this term so this totally changes the
nature of the relationship between the
customer and a sales person we
documented a far less conflict and far
less untoward interactions and we also
found that the net sales people were
actually in the most successful of all
the sales people in the dealerships that
we studied follow-up question on that
have you seen that same kind of
interaction live versus kind of using
technology or you know consider
technology computer communications in
customer service I mean kind of has that
like with chat versus talking somebody
lied i've been able to study anything in
effect there all right i haven't studied
customer services as an ethnographer i
tend not to generalize far beyond the
sites of that study sorry seemed to me
i've done a lot of shots off that
interesting thank you
okay well people thanks very much for
that really interesting conversation
we've learnt a lot about the workplace
environment the impact that new
technologies can happen workplace burn
with you learn something today about
negotiating price with car dealerships
then cover a lot of territory steve is a
wonderful asset for Stanford executive
Institute that we run every summer and
I'm looking forward to working with you
in August and HAMP program thank you
Steve
you